well you may or may not notice that i'm
having the same guest back uh in fairly
close proximity to when we last met
earlier this spring uh when we were more
locked down as a country right now we're
in her home and we're clearly not locked
down
we're not doing this on zoom we're doing
this in person and the reason that we're
visiting with the great ivy zellman
again is that she's just published her
memoir
and i can tell you writing a memoir it's
a whole different kind of work that you
you can't describe to others you have to
actually go through writing a book
and i'd like to talk about ivy being ivy
and what made ivy today
[Music]
welcome she's the co-founder of zellman
associates you just saw her other
co-founder dennis mcgill blow your brain
with the best demographics in the world
welcome ivy thank you for having me
again great to see you in person so
let's start off with um
because not an enviable position today
which is the the worst supply chain
disruption in the history of mankind but
seven years old you want to be the ceo
of mattel
a toy company well i
think it was probably the only company i
knew that was big and
i just knew that i needed to
make a lot of money and be successful so
you were seven
i was driven
when you were seven i mean i was into
thinking about what ways i would wind up
just like my dad you know being um an
executive and
thinking about wanting more so i don't
remember was laying on the floor in my
mother's bedroom while she's making the
bed and i was just laying there with my
dogs and i'm like mom i'm going to own
mattel one day and she was like good
honey
good for you i mean i don't know why i
said that i just know that well it makes
sense i mean it just it makes sense
that's the one tangible thing in our
lives when we're seven years old right
new mate but but your life took a little
bit of a right angle when you were 12
years old yes you had your formative
teenage years in the city of london what
was that like talk to us about that um
well actually my dad came home from work
and he worked in midtown in new york
city
and worked for an import export company
called london america and
the um opportunity came about that he
can live overseas for three years in
london and we would be there on a
contract for three years and so my
sisters and i were devastated i mean i
was in a public middle school high you
know junior high school for a month
and we had to leave and we had to have
our dogs quarantined it was pretty um
traumatic for all of us but i wound up
living in the suburbs of london actually
went to an all-girls
christian school and i'm jewish that
that didn't last very long
we didn't care as much as my dad was
like you know this is gonna be a great
experience for you
and i was there for three days and it
was way too hard versus the public
school i did teach the girls how to play
netball before i went to the american
school but um it was it was an
incredible experience and you know some
of my closest friends in the world i met
while living there so i look back on
that and think it was incredibly
transformative for me as an individual
you're writing
i mean you're taking the tube you're
going to concerts yeah i mean this is a
lot of independence that's that that's
that's the word i was looking for thank
you that's a lot of independence at a
very young age yes
i think it was like that when we were
growing up though i mean i think whether
it had been long island or yeah i mean i
was a turnkey kid i mean i used to take
the public bus home um because there was
no school bus so i i guess at that same
age i was pretty darn independent myself
and i used to run a little office in my
i used to have like fake money and fake
ledgers and
anyways that's right um so
in the classroom a little bit later on
in life you you were something of a of a
nudge you were a little precocious yes
you actually had an eraser hit your head
at some point what was that all about
actually that was in advanced financial
management at george mason oh sorry
so you stayed a nudge yes always but i
think that one in particular he was
pissed off um couldn't be um
more of an opposite individual in a lot
of ways but he
wrote a formula on the board and i
pointed out he made a mistake and it was
a number of things that i probably had
done and finally he just couldn't take
it and everybody was stunned and i think
we took a break
and my friends in the room were like oh
my god when we went out of the classroom
but no early on i always was a kid you
know calling out the answer probably the
one that everybody hated for being the
loudmouth
when i started college my dad told me
that
he did really poorly in statistics and
when i was in this lecture hall with 300
kids and
you know i just sat in the front row and
as far as i was concerned it was just me
and the teacher and no one else in the
room and i'm sure everybody you were the
kid in the front row yeah pain in the
ass in the front row well in middle
school i wasn't but in college i was
so um
ernst young before it was ernst young
you started off as a bean counter
i do i'm trying to
i can't square the circle with your
personality and an accountant
it's not happening well actually
when i went to
um school i went to night school and i
was taking classes and working full-time
i was working at arthur young as a
secretary i was an admin and
i knew if i got a degree in accounting
my dad told me no matter what you'll get
a job
and i was good at math and so i just
started taking you know classes in
accounting and my major was declared as
accounting
but as i started talking to arthur young
accountants and asking them you know do
you like your job you know are you happy
i got a lot of them kind of indicating
that you know it's maybe not for you
that may not be the perfect personality
fit
one of my friends uh terry lloyd who i'm
still friends with from arthur young
would laugh he's like there's you need
to do something else ivy you need to go
to wall street and i think they saw that
my personality was a little bit more
outgoing and maybe more
inclined to interact with people which
in accounting i learned quickly that
you're in a room with a lot of books and
numbers and you don't spend as much time
working with people no i mean i'm
arthur anderson offered me the moon in
the world and everything in between my
final nine hours to get to my
where i could sit for the cpa and i'm
just like and you knew it wasn't for you
i'm like no
and i mean but to be fair
looking back all these years
you'd probably agree
that accounting background remains
essential absolutely i mean to be able
to read a balance sheet
and scour through a p l and cash flow
statement i think that was a great um
foundation for
my analysis today as a stock equity
analyst people yeah people often ask me
you know what was the most important
class you took in business in business
school and i'm like
managerial accounting one of the hardest
classes i've ever had to take yes but i
survived it and it always stayed with me
more than anything else but but wall
street
so you finally get to wall street
apparently where you belong
what was your first big break
um getting a job at solomon brothers and
i got you there in what capacity um i
got a job working in their two-year
corporate finance program
and it was um roughly 70 kids that
came from undergrad that were there for
two years to
really as a sort of bridge to whatever
else in their future careers a good
training ground kind of like you know a
residency at a hospital like i work 80
to 100 hour weeks and i didn't really
know that going in but i knew that
everyone told me if you want to make a
lot of money and you want to be
successful you have to get a job on wall
street and at that time wall street was
investment banking
in the late late 80s early 90s it was
all about investment banking so getting
that job was my big break and actually i
got the job
um fortunately you know i'm one of those
people that will ask every anyone anyone
for help so even to get an interview on
wall street was difficult because i came
from a very non-traditional background
yep
but getting that job was the break and i
my dreams had come true george mason had
me um
on the front page of their newsletter
with a big picture that their state grad
ivy schneider got a job on wall street
so
dreams had come true and getting to wall
street and working at solomon i thought
i'd be there forever and i would never
leave sally and i'd never leave invest
in banking and i learned very quickly
that that wasn't the case so
so what happened next
well like most of the 70
analysts in this program i tried to go
to business school and i had student
loans i went to night school for six
years and i was still paying student
loans
but i worked tirelessly to try to get
into the best of the brightest you know
i wanted to go to harvard stanford
northwestern and if i'm going to take
student loans it's got to be the best
mba program and everyone said you have
to get an mba and i would say 99 of the
70 go to get their mba but i didn't get
into any of those three schools so at
that point i was pretty devastated i
worked so hard in my essays and my gmats
unlike my sats and applications for
undergrad so i started looking for a job
internally and fortunately for me
solomon brothers had a scandal which you
may recall with john good friend and
unfortunately the demise of what was
perceived the demise of solomon brothers
created a lot of openings at sally so
we're in the midst of a recession my job
was ending in june of 92. so earlier in
91 when i knew i wasn't getting into any
of the business schools i started
looking internally
and julius meldoutis who was the airline
analyst that i worked with as part of
the transportation team at corporate
finance recommended me for a job a role
in equity research under bruce harding
who was doing the firm a favor because
bob bishop who was our equity housing
analyst he thought the lights were going
out at sally and he left and he went to
be by side now he's actually one of my
top clients running impala as the chief
investment officer but at the time there
was an opening bruce decided to help
sally out pick up the home building and
building product stocks because he
covered snls and julius recommended me
and bruce hired me so and for me i was
just so happy to have a job to pay my
rent i'm sure and i was told all the
investment bankers are like you don't
want to go to work in equity research
they're just monkeys they just write
what management teams tell them to write
and you're going to hate it so these
were my confidants my my friends and i
really didn't care i just wanted a job
and i had i had some idea but it was it
was to pay the rent
so um
we know
looking back that uh
that you were no monkey in equity
research that you didn't let anybody
guide your views but how was it to be
kind of on wall street in that era you
know i started in 96 it was definitely a
boys club then you were kind of a tomboy
on wall street which
is kind of hard for me to wrap my head
around but that's how you described it
yeah
you know i think growing up in the
suburbs of new york out in long island
i always talk about you know i lived off
of exit 62 off the la everybody says
that lives along island we're out in a
place
near stony brook and it was a public
school i mean my graduating class was a
thousand kids
and i'm one of three sisters
and i was definitely athletic and we we
we'd get into physical altercations you
know whether it be with my sisters
or you know neighborhood girls and we
were tough
and
so being in a man's world just felt
natural for me and i never even thought
about being a woman it was more i'm just
going to kick these guys asses i'm going
to go in here and show them how it's
done
whether woman or man and i'm not saying
there wasn't hard times but i could
swear like the best of them
i can hang in the locker room it doesn't
matter look at the top of the next page
it says potty mouth
total potty mouth but i didn't i mean if
a man i'll give an example and this is
probably not politically correct but you
know i had a ceo once say to me when i
was pregnant with my third child walking
out he said you know what you sure have
a good ass for a pregnant woman no and i
looked at him and i said thank you
so as far as i was concerned i'm okay
with that you know and i maybe i
shouldn't be and i now appreciate it
could be viewed as inappropriate but and
nothing i didn't let things phase me and
guys were flirting with me or they were
joking around talking about stuff what
they did the night before i would just
get right in the conversation give a
for it so it didn't bother me and
that's i mean that that's how i was that
was how you had to be if you were to
survive positive you would never make it
and you can't be sensitive if you're
going to be in a boys world a man's club
you're going to have to learn how to
have thick skin yeah i had to live down
the the nickname of stapler because on
my first day at work i asked for a
stapler and i was told that i was lower
than the whale on the bottom of the
ocean and that i should never ask
anybody for anything ever again
one of these things stapler di martino
that was that was a lot of fun
but so
talk a little bit about because this is
something something i that that i dealt
with as well um
talk about
is it a service or a disservice that
that wall street is
such a club of ivy leaguers
um
well it depends on who you're asking you
know coming from a non-ivy league
background it was intimidating
um
i feel like the elitism was you know so
alive and obvious to me that i never
fully felt like i belonged
it's just funny because looking back now
i'm doing this almost 30 years i don't
know if it was 10 years ago i lose track
of time but i ran into a bunch of
solomon guys that my husband was having
dinner with and i went and met them for
a drink and i remember chatting with one
of them and this guy john is like we
were so intimidated by you and i was
like what you were intimidated by me
yeah yeah he's like yeah you were like
in those classes that we had to take
cause we did like six weeks of training
you were the only one that knew the
answers to those accounting questions
you were the only one that because most
of these kids that come in are like
poets they call them the english major
the history majors because they know how
to think as opposed to those that you
know are more on the finance accounting
side that are that are analytical well
analytical and more rote learning
whatever it may be but but i was just
blown away that they were intimidated by
me and i said how could you by me he
says well how'd you get in
we we you came from this non-traditional
background or you weren't from an ivy
league you knocked on the damn doors so
i had a knock on a lot of doors and i
was pretty deflated i remember going to
what i call an information interview
where you go and try to
learn about the opportunities and this
was one was that prudential and one was
at dean winner and both were women it
was hr and it was a friend that arthur
young might have been a boss where they
audited that client that would you meet
this woman she's really you know unique
and they pretty much both women
completely independent of one another
told me that i didn't have what it took
what it took to get a job at wall street
and i walked out of both of those
completely deflated
just feeling like i'm never going to get
a job wall street but i didn't give up
and i did my homework and i read a ton
of books and i kept asking and kept
asking until finally a guy at the gym
where i folded towels and worked out
sort of a barter he said i know some guy
on wall street i can introduce you to
and sure enough cj desantis who worked
at merrill lynch and fixed income agreed
to meet me for an informational
interview and that was a turning point
and had i not met with cj two hours
prior to a a real interview at solomon
brothers that dave wilson who was the um
partner that ran all of our region
that was incredibly generous to you know
take me under his wing and got me a real
interview and the guy that ran hr at
solomon he says we don't normally talk
we don't meet with non-ivy league
students our graduates and he said you
need to meet this woman she's special i
don't think that the sell side has
changed that much
since sarbanes-oxley since the financial
crisis i mean it still kind of reads the
same smells the same feels the same um
but you've you've done things
differently from day one
how did that
evolve as the 90s turned into the
oughts
years
and it was obvious that housing was
starting to uh to run hotter than maybe
it was
then maybe what was justified well it
really started out um
ironically because i covered such a
small space and i launched in august of
93 on four home building stocks and i
remember
the salesforce wouldn't have anything to
do with me at some brothers you know i'm
my stocks in total
represented less than a half a percent
of the s p 500 so
you really
couldn't get them to take you to see
investors they were just more reluctant
because it would put them at
reputational risk right so
the best way to differentiate yourself
um is to go out and talk to private
companies and learn from them and my
industry was so fragmented when i first
started covering the home builders
they represented less than 10 of all of
new home sales so it was easy to find
large private home builders whether it
be at industry associations through
conferences and so
i had to find a way to
get that client to call me back and how
do you do that
with information they're not reading in
a 10q or 10k or annual report
so
that motivated me to
learn as much as i can that would
provide them incremental but incremental
valuable information so then i actually
got through to a few clients that were
you know willing to take my call to hear
what i have to say but i also would ask
them a ton of questions like what do you
think's missing in the analysis that the
sell side does what's your view of the
housing market which stocks do you like
what do you think of this management
team and then i would have a little bit
of what i tell them i'd learn from
private builders and they'd hang up that
call and they'd be like she's awesome
and i barely would maybe say anything i
just asked a lot of questions about them
and then they started telling their
sales force or their salesperson
iv ivy schneider's really good
and then the sales force was willing to
take me out so it's kind of backwards
but i think it was being forced to
get attention through providing nuggets
that no one else had and that was the
only way to get investors to really pick
up that call and want to hear from me on
the next time i picked up the phone and
then it became self-fulfilling because
then the sales force likes you and then
the next thing you know other sales
people are willing to take you out
so i think that that digging was by
force
at some point
here in in the timeline
something called children started coming
along
when did that happen
how did it affect your tenacity
if at all i doubt it did but how
how did the
advent of becoming
a mother
working on wall street how did that work
i mean i can't i i left wall street
before i started having kids but how did
that work
you know it's just like anything you
just do it i mean you know i
remember my mother being worried that i
was never gonna get married and have
kids because i was working so much and
at one point i wasn't sure i would
either i was just you know guilty as
charged you know it focused and but i
met a man at work you know so i met
david at solomon brothers and you know
he
um could handle me you know my dad joked
at my wedding you know she looked
everywhere she lived in europe she
looked in asia she lived in the us this
is his you know speech at my wedding i'm
like thanks dad he's well eventually you
found someone that could put up with you
um but really david wanted a family and
was very um clear
that if we're going to get serious
at some point i want to move to
cleveland where i want to raise my
family close to my parents
and so ohio in ohio cleveland ohio and i
was like where's cleveland you know i
was you know no idea and i never thought
he'd actually want to move because he's
such a party guy and loves you know
great restaurants music so
we got married i got pregnant and we
moved to cleveland and i was a little
devastated i'll be honest admittedly
initially and yet when i was there i
went from a small apartment
into you know five thousand foot square
home which was
a huge home yeah and you go around and
go i can fit like five apartments yeah
and i'm jumping out of a car and david's
family was great and all his friends
that he grew up with since elementary
school were there and they had kids but
being a professional on wall street
being a mother
you know you didn't you know you're not
given any you know sort of advantage or
or freedom to like oh go be your mom
you're expected to do everything what
you always have done including traveling
so really is about great support having
people around you that you trust
but i think it's just like anything else
you just go you just do it and even
being on maternity leave you know is not
really a true maternity leave you know
you're you're available you're available
24 7. and i think that that wall street
it's expected so you don't you have
you're not afforded that luxury
no of taking time off and that's why a
lot of women leave the workforce
unfortunately at least the wall street
workforce
yeah i mean i um i mean when my twins
were born bear stearns was blowing up so
it wasn't an option at the federal
reserve at that point to kind of say you
know i'm on maternity leave i've got
twins in the nicu yeah i just
it distracted my mind at the time to
think about
bear stearns instead of
you know the two little heartbeat
monitors anyway oh my god oh it was
pretty scary um by the way
can you please share your children's
names yes because i i run around going z
squared z squared did you square it uh
zoe zachary and zia was that obviously
by design
uh well zoe was one of my favorite names
and i love the double z but at the time
we decided we weren't gonna find out if
we're having a boy or girl so we went
with
zoe or zack and then
when we had number two we were going to
go with zach or nikki so zach and then
we said well we got to stick with the z
theme now so we actually made up the
name zia
we were thinking names on like things
that rhyme and mia oh zia so and she's
she fits the names ian pretty good i'll
tell you that i literally walk around
with z squared coins and we have dogs
zozo and xander and we had to put down
zilli i know so we we've definitely got
a z theme going on
you've got two puppies yep six months
love dogs yes um
okay so let's let let's move on let's
let's move on to the sticking to your
guns the housing call to
how was that i mean that that's how we
met um that's why we met
it was not a fun life
right you were contrarian as well
i was talking to this young economist
named jan hatzius about
mortgage equity withdrawal
and how it was juicing consumption and
he was like no no this is originally
alan greenspan series and i mean
wonky geeky stuff but i'm sitting there
saying this a lot of many of these
people are pulling out of their homes
and they're getting mortgages pretty
easily to do it so anyways you saw what
was coming
and you started to be public about that
at a sell-side firm
[Music]
i mean at least i was retired off wall
street back then i was i was at the
dallas morning news i had i had security
i was getting death threats but i was
sure as hell not on the sell side saying
what you were saying
how did that evolve
well i built a network of private
companies as i mentioned earlier that at
the time was several hundred and having
the ability to
have your
your your hand on the pulse
on a daily basis boots on the ground
talking to builders and mortgage
companies and realtors but predominantly
home builders
and and them telling you that it was
crazy and stupid telling you telling you
all the time about the land inflation
and how they can't pencil returns or how
they're selling to investors and their
and there's a tremendous amount of
speculation in the market
i think it was grounded in having that
perspective and constantly
triple checking you know
whatever i had to against the realtors
what are they saying are they saying the
same thing or what are the mortgage
companies saying i remember being with
mortgage companies are like yeah we're
just giving people
we're we're approving people that don't
have jobs and be like how can you do
that well we could sell those loans to
fannie freddie so i think it was a
constant um
confirmation of what we were learning in
the field
and then triangulating it with the data
that we had that was showing
affordability was just completely out of
reach so knowing it wasn't sustainable
and there was such a
secular perception that there was a
secular shift and home ownership was
going to go to 70
and the numbers just were not adding up
and everything that we had ever
analyzed was telling us with red you
know bearing blaring lights this is not
sustainable this is not right and so we
started really doing a lot of work
around investors and that was when we
were
very vocal about our negative view
we first
published a report in july of o5 called
investors gone wild
and it was really an aggregation of
really sizing the amount of investors in
the market it was a 50 page deep dive
thematic report
and we had like a thousand people in our
conference call so every part of credit
suisse every aspect of the firm cared
what we were saying
and there were people within the firm
that were in agreement with us but the
majority disagreed of course and there
were you know definitely some um
say roads were difficult to navigate
through being out of europe bureaucratic
firm but i had a great team dennis
mcgill who's my co-founder at zellman
was a intern and became a full associate
and others along the way that you know
helped us
all to really stick to what we believe
because we were doing the research
and it's hard to you can't consciously
ignore it or if you do i don't know how
you go forward and i remember being on
conference calls and management teams
you know they would say that i was
a jihad i was at war against them and i
would ask questions and investors would
be like why is she asking about fico
scores and why is she asking about debt
to income ratios and and i was on i was
focused on the mortgage piece and i just
got clients that were getting pissed off
and telling their salespeople you know
she's asking questions that don't matter
and she's you know trying to find
information that doesn't have any impact
on the home building business so we were
triangulating the various silos the
mortgage mostly with the brokerage
community with the home builders and
most cell site analysts stay in their
lane and they only analyze the stocks
that they cover
so that got us into trouble by you know
veering outside of our lane yep
i feel like we just had a conversation
about the last two months in the housing
market but moving on
um
detractors
there's a lot of detracting going on
today if you're not
if you're not a crypto enthusiast if if
you don't believe that
fed liquidity is the only game in town
if if
if you don't believe that valuations i
mean if you believe that valuations
there's a lot of detracting going on
today for anybody who dares to
speak out
and it's uh one of the parts of your
book was was pretty it it opened it
opened up some wounds for me
by willing to be a detractor
there were some pretty mean things that
were that were done and said yeah how i
mean how
how did you navigate that
not a lot of tears my guess um
you know tough days
i think that i
had
experienced some major backlash from
even people i worked with internally
you know threatening me that
thinking they're my friend if you don't
you know turn bullish you're going to
ruin your career
[Music]
i think there were
a number of times where
i lost confidence and you know would go
home and cry to david and be like you
know he's like you know
just do what you have to do and i think
it was those hard days that made the
next day where you get up and
you just call few more of your contacts
and you just check and triple check the
work that you've been doing
but it wasn't fun to not be popular and
i don't know that i know how to do
anything different so
i just had to grin and bear it and
fortunately i had dennis and justin and
then later alan and melinda and people
around me that you know were really
supportive so i couldn't have gotten it
alone that's for sure i was never alone
in it i was with a group and even dennis
and i will talk back on those days and
you do lose confidence you always like
question yourself am i wrong like what
am i missing
i think it's those people that really
um are the most successful or the ones
that are willing to ask themselves where
am i wrong like what what am i missing
and not get complacent in their own view
and just constantly testing themselves
and their in their
their their philosophy
so uh at some point you branched out on
your own
what was leaving wall street i mean that
was
that must have been
a massive leap and the risk you're
taking on and
having
i mean having having employees you're
responsible for i'm starting to i'm
starting to channel myself through you
because
because having now you're doing it
having the responsibility of having
employees is really
stressful but what what
what made you say you know what i'm
going to go do this on my own
you know it wasn't an overnight decision
i think like everything i was pretty
methodical and prudent about approaching
it but i recognized that
this you know industry rolodex that i
had built
had value and i was really able to
provide
incremental information that no one else
could it was differentiated
marry that with internally not feeling
the love and support during those tough
periods
and then triangulating that with being
told to stay in your lane
and thinking
i can go do this on my own and then i
can expand beyond home building and
building products and go do mortgage and
go do
every other thing multi-family the home
centers and that was compelling to do a
more you were creating your own new
lanes on the highway and i wanted it i i
think if if anything it was a
combination of that and and recognizing
that while credit suites was great to me
financially i was being renumerated for
how home building stocks traded
and i wasn't didn't matter that i got on
a plane and went to talk with pimco or
did work for the asset back guys
whatever i was doing
i was renumerated on only one very small
slice of really my my full job and i
started recognizing that you know what i
i could take my franchise and go hang my
shingle and call it zellman
and i thought it would be so easy so had
i known how hard it was gonna be i don't
know that i would have done it but i
also had support of my husband who was
in agreement that you know he's like
you're crazy you make good money why
would you take that risk and when he
knew i was gonna do it he decided to
jump in and help and he really was the
person on the business side helping to
get the broker-dealer license so i was
able to focus on doing research but
there were so many things that i didn't
expect like having to get paid like as a
broker as a vendor a sell-side research
firm you know i never knew how credit
suites got paid like or dealing with hr
issues and dealing with you know
accounts receivables and payables and
all the things that are
you know you're like oh my god but i did
say
well if it doesn't work out i can always
get a job
and that's how i felt and i was crazy
too because my kids when 07 were three
five and seven i mean i how nuts was
what was i i mean in hindsight it was
the only thing you had behind you was
potty training that was it
it felt like that in hindsight but i
have to tell you when you turned 40
and that's roughly when i made the
decision yep you know the kite never
flies high enough i admittedly was
feeling like
i had grown a little complacent and to
me complacency is like almost equivalent
to death
you know boredom and not feeling
challenged that i just needed that kite
to fly higher and
it's kind of been what's pushed me into
my life it's just wanting more and not
knowing what more is but knowing it's
not going to stay this way
so um
if you don't mind discussing it you are
a breast cancer survivor
i am
how's that worked with your golf swing
not as good as i'd like unfortunately
but golf was helpful
um you know i
loved playing golf and played golf since
i was 10 years old and so i remember my
dad was shocked because i gave up
playing golf even though i was really
good because i was in
the suburbs of england and i was having
fun with my friends and i wanted to go
hang out with them and not play golf so
he was bummed
still played occasionally but really
gave it up and then in my late 20s
i realized the solomon brothers at all
these boondoggles we called it where
you'd go del webb which was publicly
traded back then would have these sun
city excursions and you'd go and
everybody would go sit in meetings and
then they'd go play golf go play so i
said to my dad i said i want to play
golf again and he was thrilled so i went
to houston and he suited me up and um
said he says you still got it you still
can you know you can kill the ball so i
started playing muscle memory
and then breast cancer changed that so
it was hard to
deal with breast cancer but the
consequences of breast cancer really
didn't become that apparent until way
later
but i think when you when i found out
that i had cancer i admittedly intend to
be um a realist about things i wasn't
afraid of dying i just you know was like
how long is it going to take i mean it
was kind of like
okay pragmatist ivy ever the pragmatist
my husband just was dying over me
because i had my first lumpectomy
um which was followed by a second lump
technique with his followed by a
mastectomy and then there was more
problems post mastectomy but
after my lumpectomy i um
was on
painkillers and from the surgery and i
was on the phone talking to you know
sales people or clients and he's like to
the salesforce memo do not let ivy talk
to anyone on percocet so
it it was kind of like this can't get in
my way i'm not going to stop
and i never really worried about it but
it just kept coming and just kept coming
and there were some really dark days but
i think you focus on
as a survivor like the importance of
health
and recognizing the most important thing
is your family and i my dad really
helped me who i adore
and he said to me you know you need to
recognize that on your tombstone it's
not going to say iv ivy zellman the
housing analyst you hope it doesn't you
hope it says ivy zellman a loving mother
and and react and realizing what was
really important and i think
there were days that it was tough to get
out of bed and feeling sorry for myself
and i think that's where my husband
really came in and kicked my ass he's
like you've got three babies that need
you to get up and go take care of them
so having the kids made it easier
because i can see where you can
you know get yourself into a negative
state and stay there
um
so i'm gonna i'm gonna finish up with
something on a very personal note
because i'm i'm i've become your friend
over the last few months uh you have
very strong feelings about
not just
work not just balance in your life
family and work you have very strong
feelings about the importance of friends
in your life
and i think you can share some wisdom
uh with the viewers because i think that
that's something that
that a lot of people let go by the
wayside in life
and shouldn't right
well for me really the friends in my
life are my family like the women that
are
at my side from you know elementary
school
to
you know meeting women
15 years ago that i met through like
jennifer through my daughter's
kindergarten class and and you know
being friends with her son but i think
you know when i meet people and i
connect like you'll never get rid of me
now you know i will be
always reaching out and being proactive
and trying to see how you're doing and
being vulnerable with you and letting
you know who i am and i think all of us
are kind of apprehensive at times to
really be open and
talk about your real feelings or what's
going on with you and
i think having that connection with
other women
has really been the key to my success to
having them at my side through thick and
thin most time on the phone bitching
about the kids or complaining about what
your husband did wrong and you need that
sounding board but also to encourage you
and lift you higher sure and be there
when you are um either laughing working
on this ivy move on move on
absolutely
it's it's really the ingredients of my
success and i don't know what i would do
without him i just got back from a girls
trip in in dublin ireland you should
have came with us yeah that was i saw
those pictures
but it's making sure you make time right
and and not you know like too many women
especially when have kids you know they
can't go or their husband is you know
not around to take care of the kids and
i just think you have to make time for
your friends and make that you know
extra half an hour in your day to call
them and check in and ask them how
they're doing i think those things
really ultimately give you big payback
yeah i just i just reunited with uh 13
of my closest friends
two of which i hadn't seen in more than
a decade in in italy and incredible
our takeaway was we need to do this more
often shame on us shame on us we've
look how good we feel right um so
lots of laughing you know they laughter
they say that laughter is the best
medicine right absolutely
um all right so we haven't talked about
housing and we're not going to
because i want for i want for everybody
to go out and read give me shelter uh be
sure and give gimme shelter
great rolling stone song to your
daughters especially i highly recommend
it
and i want to thank you for all your
time this afternoon and how inspiring
your memoir is to
so many
individuals whether they be men women
children but especially
friends and i just thanks for inviting
us up to your world and i look forward
to talking about housing we'll talk
about that in six months wonderful thank
you really appreciate it
[Music]